HERE THE BLUE JACKETS LOVE BEING
AT ATTEMPT.
>> DRAW ONE BY YOU WHAT, BOTH TS
HAVE ENOUGH SKILL TO BE
EXTREMELY ENTERTAINING BUT THEY
ALSOSO OFF TO THE BENCH.
APPROACHING THE EIGHT-MINUTE
MARK.
JACKETS WITH BUT
NOW THAT'S KURALY GETS IT,
ROBINSON ALREADY BOARDS, IN THE
PLAY.
AND LUNDESTROM
AND HOW THEY'RE PLAYING.
THESE LINE C CORNER.
SILFVERBERG, JACKETS COME BACK,,
TAKE THE ICE, AND GO DECISION C.
>> YES, WEPLAY, BACK AT FULL STR
THE DUCKS AND DOWN THE WING,LUE.
LACKING LINEUP FOR SURE AND
WHAT A LEADEYSDALE, YET ANOTHERE
IMPRESSIVE YOUNGSTERS ON THAT L.
RIB DRIVEN TO THE ICE THERE BYEP
ASID WELL.
THAT WAS HOFFMAN AND JENNER
TOGETHER, NO
PENT A LUTE F TIME IN THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE TONIGHT. NET.
REGULATION BOARD SOUNDININ IN.
RAKELL, 15 SECON JACKETSCOMES D,
MOVING IN. IT.
>> SO IT WILL BE TROY
JEERS FROM THE CROWD HERE.
TERRY, OFF THE CROSS BAR.
>> YEAH, HE G.
>> OFF THE STICK JACKETS SECONDR
HERE..
>> IT GOES JUST WIDE.
>> IMPRESSIVE.E. WIDE, DIDN'T
IMPRESSIVE.